reunimos a siete profesores de yoga soy
profesor de yoga soy profesor de dicción
soy profesora de yoga soy profesora de
yo soy profesora de yoga soy profesor de
yoga soy profesora de yoga
uno es un impostor si el grupo descubre
quién es el impostor ganará un premio en
efectivo
si el impostor sobrevive él ganará el
premio
esto es el impostor
voy directo a la yugular los profesores
de yoga saben que existen ocho pasos del
yoga si en verdad eres un profesor
deberías saber cuáles son los diremos en
orden empezando por ti cuál es el primer
paso a no recuerdo cuál me llamas bien
tú qué dices
no sé hablar sánscrito dylan español
sólo he trabajado con corp awards yoga y
no te enseñan la filosofía del yoga bien
terceros son losas frena llamas no me lo
sé en orden pero sé que hay unos ya he
claro sí que güiza para ti y ahora sí
evidentemente está preparada pero por
otro lado creo que se lo busco en google
todo lo que podría relacionarse con el
yoga dijeron todas las que quería decir
que todavía quedan tres días decirme
cuáles son tengo que decirte cuál es lo
que quiero
si puedes bueno ya sé quién podría ser
el impostor
en mi opinión quizá tú eres el impostor
todos los días me gusta el cristal que
lleva qué chakra activa
activa el séptimo chakra
cuánto tiempo llevas haciendo yoga casi
toda mi vida tú qué dices estás muy
callada yo sin mucho tiempo presión
presión versión cada vez que lo veía
ella bajaba la mirada creo que estaba
escondiendo algo cuánto duró tu
entrenamiento para ser profesor
quizá todavía estoy estudiando
entonces eso hace que no se asombro
socio excelente preguntas
[Música]
parece que estaba buscando cómo
responder y no sabía de qué estaba
hablando en realidad
para mí leo es el más sospechoso de
todos sobre todo por la ropa que tenía
puesta los profesores no usan shorts tan
cortos y ajustados
a
[Aplausos]
creo que porque uso coronas de oro en
mis dientes y mido 190 creen que soy un
jugador de basket o algo así segunda
ronda hacer yoga bien comencemos con
perro boca abajo empieza la altura de la
cadera dedos separados
pierna derecha arriba y hacia atrás
la rodilla hacia la nariz contextuales
mantenlo aprieta tal vez equilibra te en
un brazo
tal vez se extiende t tal vez dobla tal
vez vueles
o tal vez no linda práctica pero eso no
es una clase comenzamos con posición de
mesa muñecas a la altura de los hombros
rodillas a la altura de las caderas
mirada arriba posición de la vaca la del
gato
muevan las caderas lado al lado hagan
círculos y
es bueno para el cuerpo
no me van a eliminar asignar a la
postura más más difícil que me sé si
haré una postura que es para algún
obsesionado con el yoga sólo haré snr es
la única así que haremos esto párate de
manos hazlo házlo levántate hazlo hazlo
lo logró
[Música]
hoy
i
ya no
debe ser una profesora mira su ropa y
además suena esa ropa te da superpoderes
bien esa es una postura estándar e
incluso siguió respirando
[Risas]
[Música]
quería ver algo más quería escuchar que
hablara mientras hacía su rutina o algo
más haré mi postura favorita
está bien
[Risas]
que me dejaste
[Música]
voy a hablarles de uno de mis
equilibrios de brazos favoritos llamado
escapada vaca sana o postura del cuervo
pero mi forma favorita de entrar es
desde el perro boca abajo llevar una
pierna hacia arriba llevarlo a la parte
posterior del brazo encuentra la parte
posterior del tríceps donde hay menos
inestabilidad comienza a doblar los
codos y luego cambia cambia cambia hasta
que tu pierna trasera se pone ligera
entonces tal vez puedas levantar la
pierna que está atrás verdad y luego tal
vez arquear tu espalda desde aquí
[Música]
futuro de leo dudo de nora pero jesse
aurora
les parecía bastante tímida durante su
rutina
[Música]
a partir de ahora por cada vez que
expulsen a alguien que no sea el
impostor el premio se reducirá a la
mitad la mitad así que si todo el mundo
está seguro de quién es el impostor
puede terminar el juego ahora pero si la
mayoría tiene dudas el juego continúa
por favor levanten la mano si quieren
seguir jugando
pensé que era aurora y pensé que le
habíamos sacado por eso quería terminar
si yo también pensé que era ella no
hablo a través de la noche tampoco dijo
nada pero su rutina fue loca no fue algo
básico lo que complica todo es que
cualquiera puede ser un yogui
bien así que mi pregunta es cuál es la
parte más difícil de ser un profesor de
yoga no me digas que estar la clase
porque todos sabemos que esa no es la
parte más difícil del rey' del yoga
enseñar su filosofía y luego encarnar la
realmente eso es lo que digo en mis
clases no estamos simplemente caminando
por la calle podemos practicar yoga
mientras lo hacemos y entonces me
encuentro como corriendo en la calle
que es lo más difícil de enseñar
no lo sé creo que depende del día en el
que practique o de clases así que
realmente depende ya sabes soy humano y
a veces tengo mal día o simplemente no
quiero hablar
de poseerlos entiendo dijo algo así como
que algunos días no estoy de humor y mi
cuerpo no lo está y yo dije eso no es
tan difícil porque enseñas yoga estaba
muy deprimida demasiado para vivir muy
deprimida y el yoga me salvó hice el
cambio que quieres el yoga cambia todo
lo relacionado con la forma en que te
ves a ti mismo en el mundo como ves el
mundo y si todos los seres humanos del
planeta practicaron yoga no estaríamos
en esta situación ha crecido mucho a
través de mi propia práctica e
impartir eso a otras personas es el
mayor regalo de todos creo que esa es la
intención y el propósito de todos ya
todos lo dijeron creo que tienes razón
creo que yo tengo la razón yo creo que
ellos tienen razón
su respuesta fue más corta que las de
todos los demás está más callada que el
resto la gente que es muy reservada me
parece sospechosas
[Música]
por favor haz en la mano si quieren
seguir jugando
están dando clases si las clases
presencial donde en un centro de yoga
lunes miércoles y domingo
es igual yo pasé como un mes entero
atravesando el país para mudarme para
casas y que en ese tiempo no di clases
bueno chicos creo entender por qué
alzaron sus luces leo creo que tú eres
usamos lo mismo bien acabemos con esto
dime cuándo fue tu primera clase de yoga
yo pienso que leo hace muchas preguntas
si no contesta ninguna así que eso me
hace pensar que ahora sólo somos cuatro
y se está poniendo nervioso primera
clase de yoga 2008 entré y salí diciendo
esto es para viejas no me interesa y
luego porque un año más tarde me
patearon el trasero en una clase de
nivel 2 y nunca dejé de ser estaba en la
secundaria y fui a la clase de yoga
también pensé que era pura palabrería
no entendía era simplemente como se
hablaran de no no sé cosas espirituales
estoy haciendo esto y luego mi amigo me
convenció de ir a una clase más tarde y
fue una experiencia muy diferente
y esa respuesta fue la que me confirmó
que ese es el impostor no fue una
respuesta muy realista en mi opinión
[Música]
tenemos un empate
leo y jesse ustedes tendrán
quince segundos bien tomé mi primera
clase cuando estaba en secundaria me
enamoré de la disciplina he estado
practicando durante unos diez años con
cuatro maestros diferentes de este
equilibrio hasta vinyasa y ya está quizá
puedas nombrar todas las posturas todo
el día pero si no sientes el yoga en tu
corazón
no creo que seas el profesor lo siento
por ti killing in a tania discuten para
tomar una decisión
ah
por favor haz en la mano si quieren
seguir jugando
si las luces verdes significa que
sacaron al impostor y que han ganado si
la luz es roja significa que el impostor
sigue en el set y perdieron el juego
[Música]
por favor impostor ahora dé un paso al
frente y muestre se en 3 2 1
de
haberlo descubierto
chicos lamento haberles mentido de
verdad me encanta el yoga y sueño con un
día poder dar clases de verdad me
gustaría dejas de mentir cuando lo hace
jubilee vive intensamente